hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive Bliss game to share with you
that was played recently on chess.com
this was played on June 8th on the white
end nihal sarin and he's playing against
Magnus Carlson
it's only a three minute game but still
an instructive one
especially in this end game phase a
couple nice points we could take
something away from
this early stage starts off quiet enough
we have an exchange Carol Khan
things do sharpen though with White's
next two moves
Bishop B5 and Knight E5
so I'll throw this to you as a pop quiz
how would you react to White's last move
feel free to pause the video
okay I'd say it's very easy to go wrong
here as black
I've gone wrong myself in this position
before
there's two threats in the position
that's why I think it's very easy to go
wrong here
this is the first thread I think of when
I see this position
and the move I've played before in this
situation is Rook C8 defending C6 and
saying hey I'm also on a half open file
but that's going to fail
to this sequence
the capture on C6 and then Bishop A6
where's this guy going
you're out of squares Rook these two
Bishops
guard all squares from The Rook
white in short
will win the exchange after Rook C8
what about Queen CA well
Queen C8 does not factor in this second
thread I'm speaking of
the second threat in the position is G4
this move is only available after the
Knight goes to E5
the Knight
and the Queen
are supporting G4
this is a serious problem for black what
is the problem exactly well this guy is
running out of squares
after H4 how do you deal with H5
produce a square for the bishop
in comes Knight takes bishop and you
have to do what take away from the
center create two holes deep in your
Camp two light Square weaknesses when
your opponent has an unopposed light
Square Bishop you are asking for trouble
this is already considered a decisive
Advantage for white
so on this move 8 black must mix defense
with attack
Queen B6 fits that criteria defensive C6
pressure on the bishop pressure on the
pawn
in this game C4 is played defending the
bishop
if white addresses this Threat by
capturing the Knight
and then going for this second idea G4
is not the same because Queen D4 is
there and white has some problems to
deal with Bishop pressure night pressure
x-raying the G4 Pawn
the bishop backs off there's Bishop
takes Pawn
okay in this game C4
Pawn takes Pawn
and the reply to this is A4 defending
the bishop
an important line to look at is Queen A4
this would force an only move by black
the only move is A6 to address this
pressure on the diagonal
try and get rid of the bishop as soon as
possible
if Bishop takes Pond there's Queen takes
B2 also with an ID of B5 next
and if Bishop takes Knight we're taking
with the pawn and we have some Queen B5
moves
in many lines from here to release the
pressure on the diagonal
okay but in our game it is A4
Bishop D3
Knight D takes C4 check
and we get a couple minor piece
exchanges in there approaching this end
game phase now Queen has to react to
this threat
and also watch out for Knight D6 check
she's staying off of C7 staying off of
this open file
Knight E5 I like the
Knight going to the edge here it seems
more invasive pressure on C6 and the
weakened B7 Pawn instead of the center
point
from here black says go ahead take the
pawn
I want to get castled
and okay white is up the pawn but has
but black has more activity better
developed side here
black will soon get the pawn back now it
took about a minute some fun notes about
this game it took about a minute for
Carlson to get to this point in the game
and about another minute to complete the
game
the reaction here by white
is to go to F3 and after that move Rook
C4 hits with the fork
black soon gets the pawn back
any other tries here for white to hang
on to the pond such as Rook C1
not really a great attempt I don't think
after Queen D6 what are you doing to
defend the bishop
do you really want to go into a pin
if you move the bishop now the queen is
overloaded
defend the Rook defend the pawn black
would be able to exchange Rooks and get
the pawn back Queen takes D4
any other attempt at this point here one
other move to look at Bishop B5 this
does stop
The Rook C4 pivot
but it's no longer there watching out
for Knight E4
and this move can hit it's suggesting
here best for white is to go uncastled
to play Queen D3 in other words and
allow the check and then Step Up
okay
what's the downside if the queen goes
here well she could be kicked
with a five and she now must leave
defensive D4 and this position here is
already considered close to winning for
black
okay in our game the bishop simply goes
back
The Rook C4 hits can't save these two
you defend this one A4 Falls
so white
says I'm just going to Castle go ahead
get the material back
Queen takes D4 Queen exchange on board
fish lean end game
where do we go from here
Can you spot Carlson's 21st move took
about two seconds to pull this one off
what move would you play here okay
feel free to pause the video
here we go
G5
so when I initially skimmed through this
game this is the first position that
really grabbed my attention I thought to
myself how many players would actually
pull this move off
um
black is with G5 doing what exactly
he's Thinking Beyond a flight Square
what is a train of thought in this end
game well my opponent has major pieces
on board I still need a flight Square so
let me ah do I go with H6 or G6 no
black is with this move really
extracting the maximum he's looking
Beyond this flight Square he's looking
to inconvenience this bishop with G4
he's looking to have this Pawn
cramp the white king side structure in
some way
so
the fewer the pieces there are on board
I think you could look to be more
ambitious with the pawn advances in
front of your king
I mean this would be a crazy move to
play if there was still a queen on board
or even a dark Square Bishop for white
on board
but it is much more simplified now we
could think again beyond the flight
Square
from here H3
H5
G3 G4 Chop Chop here we go
this Pawn has a cramping effect on the
king side structure it has robbed not
only the bishop of a square
okay it's on G2 it has robbed the king
of a square it no longer has G2
now a word of caution this idea of
putting the pawn up to G4 you don't do
this in just any situation
for instance if there are no Rooks on
board
to position to fix one of your own pawns
on a light Square you may very well be
asking for trouble it's always a
potential Target for that Bishop but
there is more at play here there are
more pieces involved and black has in
the crosshairs now the F2 Pawn
he's looking to next put the two Rooks
on the second Rank and it's very
difficult to defend F2
you have to go into a strictly defensive
position no there really isn't an active
defense of the F2 Pawn as we will soon
see
so this Pawn is actually Paving the way
for some nice mating attacks potentially
as well it could maybe support a knight
on this square or this Square maybe
getting a rook here one day
more positives than negatives
the black Pawn on G4
from here activate the Rook
at this point the white Rook goes to C7
and we have the B Pawn and a pawn being
exchanged
is there any other attempt suppose
this Rook defends the B2 Pawn not with
Rook B1 because that would fall but
let's say Rook A2 looking next to go
after this Pawn
well that's not gonna work
for instance
Rook C5 in this position there's a back
rank problem
and we really get to see this cramping
effect the G4 Pawn has because this
check is in there and what do you do as
white
if you block with the bishop incomes
Knight E4 hitting the rook and next up
there's Knight D2 taking advantage of
the pinned Bishop
what's the other option King H2
King G7 what are you doing about this
it's a big problem for white
you may think to move the bishop
doesn't matter check here
and here is just one instance of a
mating net
available because of this earlier
decision
move 21
G5
Pawn on G4
the squares it's taken away from the
King
problem here for white this is a this is
a winning position
okay
in this game it is simply Rook C7 Rook
takes B2 Rook takes A7
white must defend F2
where's the ideal placement for a black
Rook
behind the pass Pawn Rook A2
white advances The Pawn King Improvement
for black
and now a reposition for the Knight
considered even better
for black in this position is to tuck
this Knight right behind this Pawn
to get it to
the G5 Square this is considered best
coordinates really well with that G4
pawn and it freezes that Bishop any
Movement by the bishop will give up one
of these two Knight jumps
okay
Carlson's idea is to coordinate with the
pawn by going to E5 focusing in on that
F3 Square
Knight D7 Bishop B7 Knight E5
get out of the ponds way before it could
move Black's putting some pressure here
stopping this Pawn from moving at this
point white tries to get behind the past
Pawn tries to overtake
these Rook positions
in a way Rook d8
Rook D1 and nearby White has this idea
get to A1 and then we're ready to push
the pawn how do you defend against that
black goes with Rook A5 and meets Rook
A1 with Rook A2 this ensures that the
black Rook will remain right behind that
past Pawn black will maintain control
over the a file in other words
from here a pair of Rooks are exchanged
white Rook is now activated there is no
coordinated pressure on F2 right now
black king improves
and now black is going after F2 with the
Knight
at this point black says I'm going to
switch my attention to this base point
try to go after this Pawn but this is a
this is not a way to defend at this
stage for white
uh one of the only defending moves here
for white is to play Rook C2 a fancy
move there
that's your way to defend F2
give up the rook and then this guy gets
to advance
this is the suggestion by the engine to
go into this ending and try to hold it
from here
okay Rook C2 not played
in this game Rook C6
and from here Knight takes F2 how are we
getting to this Pawn
how we defending it well just in the
nick of time
night check Knight G5
and everything is safe so that night
is quite the traveler where did he go he
was on E5
and from E5 he went here there here
circled back and he's there to defend
the base point
and nearby he's ready to go here and
take the pawn with check this happens
there's not really much white can do
about it this Rook by the way is what
you would say
optimally placed
behind the pond and also cutting off the
king
cannot get to the second rank
so from here is Rook C2 by this point it
is just too slow
to get this in this Pawn advancing
white needs too many moves before
he could advance that pawn meanwhile
this Pawn is falling with check
and with that last capture this guy is
now passed
one more move
and white resigns
and that is to Simply push the furthest
Advanced pass Pawn F4 white resigns
nearby F3 F2 would check F1 equals Queen
mate
too slow to try something like this for
promotion because black is already there
and that's a quick Checkmate for you so
white knows this is coming at this stage
and simply throws in the towel
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video
in the comments section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
thank you
foreign